yeah theo vaughn um i love you man
thanks for being here man
explain your [ __ ] get up bro nothing
well this is what do you mean this
yeah this is just a scarf this is like a
wintertime piece
more for you know when you want to just
kind of keep a little bit of the
elements off your neck
right and uh huh yeah debris anything
keep your uh keeps your mullet warm too
[ __ ] yeah
so i got that with the balloon gang
piece bruh
somebody made this for me yeah um what
does gang gang mean bro
it just means gang two times in case
somebody didn't hear you the first time
aha
right right for people with learning
disabilities yeah learning disabilities
in their ears
what else happened man not too much dude
yeah
yeah um we haven't talked we've talked
about how you killed it in australia or
what brah
have we oh man those people are great
huh australian
we've never been i've never been ben no
we've never been as a as a group as a
group by ben
you've have you ever performed over
there no no i've been i went
before you know what i mean yeah because
people would love you man you think so
oh yeah they don't you know what it is
brah it's like
i don't know how to go there and i need
to be invited
no no it's not anything like that what
it's like is just that you should go
over there man and those people would
love you i think yeah
[Laughter]
doing stand-up i mean was it because i i
found when i would play south africa
brah
um they they got all the jokes they get
all the jokes right they speak english
yeah oh yeah man if you're in south
africa man they play
they definitely uh i feel like they get
a lot of jokes over there
is that what you felt like yeah yeah but
like
but you know but i meant to ask you bro
because they are the abba ambrose i love
australia
what they call aborigines yeah asking
him the whitest guy in the world
he could think all the way through his
genealogy
nobody would know zero answers
in his dna man okay
you gotta go with flip schultz over here
and ask him man schultz bro
sorry yeah man wrong name man dude let
me just say something right now uh your
attitude right now your eyes are baggy
what happened to you bro i think i'm
just tired
he's always had baggy eyes it's extra
baggy it's like the emperor from [ __ ]
returning the jedi palpatine
yeah you think i'm palpatine no but when
he became that you wanted these bro
oh wow your eyes were crying bro put
them on man you got chinese eyes right
now bruh
dude people used to always call me
little china boy when i was in uh
like in the summertime when i was at
summer camp because
they had like remember um
it's not dander what is it that comes
off of nature you know what i'm talking
about holland
pollen so yeah they have it everywhere
and anyway you go outside they do
dude yeah i know this guy he's learning
every day bro
yeah you don't know he doesn't believe
us yeah like
it was a joke there's pollen out there
bro they're pollen everywhere dude they
have pollen looking at you right now bro
from point blank range think about that
that's how powerful it can be milling
around in front of a point-blank range
yeah man and it would get in my eyes and
i couldn't open my eyes at all
for sometimes even almost a month like i
could barely get my eyes open a little
bitty bit
so they would call you china boy yeah
they would call me china boys you know
what you don't
do you have eyelids yeah baby babies
your eyes
have two eyelids you do yeah
yeah when you do that it looks like you
don't you could be asian
well the reason why is you have
chromatic he has yeah like um
it's chromatic bro it's chromatic yeah
it's like riding on
yeah i don't know if that's a good thing
bro it's like i meant to say you're like
you know mentally yeah a little bit oh
dude you ate a dog proof remember what
are you dog poo yeah but you only had
one piece
but still man i never did that
i know you never tried poo i've never
had any
yeah yeah yeah do you have any tips
about um getting a mullet and how to
maintain a mullet because
captain lee is gonna get you're ready to
go deep